think about what I just said think about
how far that actually goes this industry
sells vanilla ice cream and it's and it
yells it in a place where nobody hears
it that's what this is all about this
whole week is about selling vanilla ice
cream and selling it to a room that
doesn't exist
[Music]
hey guys let's that's a hardcore setup
so I'll take it
I'm really excited to do this this is
like the only consistent thing that I've
been doing it can you know for me unlike
a lot of you I didn't really grow up you
know aspiring to be in the industry or
and didn't spend the first 35 years of
my life in the industry I'll try to
speak up because I know it's loud so
just to give you context because I'm
sure most or half of you don't know I
run a company called vaynermedia I
started ten years ago with my brother AJ
my career you know I was an entrepreneur
I grew up I was born in the Soviet Union
I came to the US when I was a little kid
very immigrant kind of upbringing let's
go yep yeah go boopadoo ski yeah so yes
Mike yeah everybody want to wait no race
should we do QA yep
yeah Pia who could have built three in
1978 my I really understand it I like
because I don't use it like Russian
people make fun of me but but if I went
to like Moscow for a week you know if I
just heard it enough it's really
interesting growing up an immigrant
because you're you're outside worlds
this new place but the house is still
the old school you know right that's
like something I don't see you know you
hear it I've heard other people talk
about it but I don't think it's talked
about enough and then more importantly
you know I wonder what that actually
means you know there's got to be
something pretty profound about living
two different worlds and it manifests in
like such fun inside jokes like
for example I don't take any medicine
ever like it's like a hardcore thing in
my face it's very like hardcore Eastern
Europe like it's unbelievable how much
that's like in my culture like I'm just
like food like just growing up in the
80s in America where like the it's been
amazing with the Whole Foods and the
Wegmans and just these progressive food
culture in America but I like in the 80s
it was like six things so my friends
would come over and like I remember
nobody in America in the 80s or 90s
knew what pomegranate was but nobody but
it was like a hardcore Russian thing so
like like people had come to my house
but the [ __ ] is like it's just like
literally like look at it for like five
minutes
so should I go since I got quieter or
okay so what's there's a there's a lot
of things I want to talk to you about
and I want to do even more Q&A because I
think context matters but 2/3 him up the
conversation I think what was really
cool was you know I was I was a lemonade
stand kid I was a shovel snow wash cars
like always my true hobby to this day i
garage sale and like do all these weird
things cuz my true hobby is business
like I genuinely love it I'm sure like
for some of you that were probably so
happy that this was an industry because
you grew up drawing or creating or
whatever like oh wait that's a job like
that's how business is for me like when
I have downtime I'm trying to start side
businesses so love the business my you
know grew up in an environment where my
dad worked every minute to try to make
it in the new world and he eventually
owned a liquor store in New Jersey I was
dragged into that when I was 14 and
really from day one I started doing two
things that are interesting to me I
started doing a lot of UI UX which in in
the way I would say that was I started
move in my dad's store around I stand
behind the register and it wasn't that
busy right like you know you know where
I could watch almost every customer walk
in and where would they go and what
would they buy an intuitive as 14 I
would understand like why do we send
them that way where we sell stuff that's
not as expensive as over here
like really in highness stuff in last
five years I've recalled even lemonade
when I was six years old instead of
standing behind my own lemonade stands I
got my friends to do it because I would
literally walk up and down the streets
of New Jersey watching cars drive by to
try to figure out what tree or what
posts to put a sign on so I've been
truly intuitively chasing attention my
whole life as a matter of fact it's
gonna bubble up in a minute
one of the biggest reasons I push
against television advertising and think
it's grossly overpriced and overrated is
not because I don't believe in the craft
or a 30-second video it's that I don't
believe people are consuming them you
know like that I think that needs to
matter you could literally make the
greatest thing of all time it's kind of
like the tree in the forest like you're
gonna spend nine months making something
that nobody sees seems like a waste of
time
so was that kind of kid in I'll fast
forward because I want to get into the
meat in 1996 I launched one of the first
three e-commerce wine businesses in
America
my dad at a liquor store we were not we
were in a middle-class area but there
was affluent towns around us
I saw people wanted wine I started
reading about wine like crazy got super
educated about wine as a 15 16 17 year
old kids super weird in the hunt in
hindsight launched in 96 had email open
rates of like 90 percent was the first
advertised like day one advertiser on
Google Search day one five cents a click
no like typing in words that had nobody
typed like like Cabernet had no bids or
like crazy [ __ ] built my dad's business
from a three to a sixty million dollar
business very quickly that changed our
immigrant life as you can imagine kinda
made it was fancy like you know in the
wine world like whiz kid articles AP all
the things you would kind of want and
then YouTube came out and four months
after YouTube came out I intuitively
understood it was going to be big and I
started legitimately one of the first
long-form shows on YouTube every day
five days a week
20 minutes me in front of a camera
tasting four wines and talking about it
completely exploded like hardcore web
2.0 phenomenon was a dig doc
and Raddatz and boing-boing and just got
a lot of coverage there was a couple of
vlogs diggnation rocketboom I mean you
guys are so young it's like this was
before there was a video on YouTube that
had a million views a video so like
super early got national attention Conan
O'Brien had me on his show like the
whole [ __ ] Internet was hitting me up
like do it for us like it was that small
of a kind of like it's crazy to even
like talk about this right now because
first of all cuz it's only 2007 it's not
that long ago go on it went super viral
and then I realized that this whole
world was gonna be huge and that is I
was super right about e-commerce email
and Google AdWords and I did great but
then I started reading articles about
Google Sal but you know going public and
YouTube selling for 1.7 billion dollars
and I was like this talent I have I
might be able to use it for something
that more than selling some more
champagne or Bordeaux and so I decided
to become an angel an angel investor in
early-stage startups the first three
companies I invested in were Facebook
Twitter and Tumblr yeah it's like you
know obviously that kind of changed the
course of my life this was all way I
mean I bought my Facebook stock from
Mark's parents like early [ __ ] that was
good
changed the course of my life made it in
a totally different way and then I did
something interesting it's 2009 my
brother's about to graduate from college
he's 11 years younger to me were super
tight we knew we wanted to do something
together I've I'm now getting super
attention from like family offices you
know global billionaires hedge funds
you know people that want me to raise
hundreds of millions of dollars to do a
fund to invest because I can pick them
and that was probably the most
interesting point in my career where I
could have easily gone down the path of
extremely in my opinion easy money
I don't know how much you know about you
know running a VC firm but you get two
percent of the overall money you raise
just for managing it and you get 20% on
the back end after you pay it back you
raise three four five hundred million
dollars you're making a lot
out of money a year just to take
meetings and I remember just knowing in
my heart like intuitively even though it
was extremely attractive I was young I
was 34 that I didn't want to not be a
practitioner I'm gonna say something
pretty interesting right now which I
genuinely think is true and it's a
hyperbolized statement but I think it's
true there's not a single person that
can right now that makes more content on
a daily basis than me I put out 50 to
100 pieces of content a day across 7 and
10 platforms like like to be the person
at this event and I don't know if how
many people on earth exist right now
that produced as much content as I do
I'm posting again fifty to a hundred
pieces of period of a day across
Facebook Instagram LinkedIn Twitter
podcasts I'm I'm a deep practitioner
right you know and and it's fun you know
some of my lead creatives are here like
it's fun sometimes when we jam like I
love reminding my company I'm like look
I'm actually doing this and there's
something very powerful about that I'm
not I da ting producing look you know
long-form video but I'm putting out
content and so I knew that that's who I
was and so I didn't I literally went
completely the other way instead of
going down that huge financial path I
decided to build and don't get it
confused
one of the worst businesses you can
build which is a client service creative
business now let me tell you why I did
it
my ambition 10 years ago stays true
today I want to buy some of the most
nostalgic brands that have ever existed
when the next economy collapses so when
this economy finally collapses I want to
go by KitKat's bubblicious k-swiss you
know Ralph Lauren I want to buy Brandt's
and then I want to be the CEO of it and
what I knew then was I understood small
businesses
I understood Silicon Valley I didn't
understand fortune 500 businesses but I
wasn't gonna go get a job so I decided
to start the agency because at that
point I realized marketing was my
superpower hanging out with all those
Silicon Valley Titans why was I invited
to the dinner
why were they listening to me it's
because they were great a tech but I
really
one of the biggest reasons forget about
the current way people view Mark
Zuckerberg and Facebook Mark Zuckerberg
deep understanding of human psyche was
the number one reason we connected I
think I'm an extremely good marketer
because I think this entire thing that
we're at right now is an internal b2b
ecosystem and the only thing I pay
attention to is the end consumer I know
so little about what's going on here
this is this is literally the first
three years I was here I only did this
event I didn't know anything else you
guys remember I know Harriet just joined
us to run comms from BB do she's
incredible I'm still asking her on the
way here she's like we were fine fine
Alyssa what's a cold shortlist she's
like we were shortlisted for a bunch of
stuff that I'm like I don't even know
what I literally thought it was finalist
like I still de Adam yes sir we want a
silver thing and I was like what does
that mean like I still am so deeply
unaware of what's happening here not out
of audacity not out of disrespect I
actually love coming here the vibe I
love hanging with you guys I love this
it's just that everything I think about
is the consumer it's the only thing that
matters and and that's why I believe
that you know and I'm humbled by some
you know the most interesting or one of
the one of them oh we're doing some of
the most interesting things because we
just see it different we just see it
different and the way we see it is
practical so I mean the far majority of
what you've already worked on you would
have never consumed that's the [ __ ]
truth and I think that's that's my
aspiration to come to things like this I
actually have a conversation about what
the hell's going on
right like creativity is amazingly fun I
think that we have to be very thoughtful
that somebody's paying us to make
something happen you know I think
there's a lot of audacity that seeps
into this craft where it becomes about
ideology and and selfish behavior i
watch creatives and strategists make
decisions all the time based on what
they want to blow up a building they
want to meet John Legend they want this
joke to see the
world it has nothing to do with what the
client needs and definitely nothing to
do with does the end customer care and
so I think a lot about that and so we
started vaynermedia you know it's
interesting my aspirations were a couple
things I didn't know first of all the
first 45 people that works for my agency
had zero days of agency experience I
mean you want to talk about a [ __ ]
[ __ ] show like we want a million-dollar
scope from Pepsi and on the way out the
guy grabs me and says hey incredibly
provocative you're gonna get the
business this is incredible so what
we're looking for it's 2009 then he goes
he goes
one piece of advice I'm like please
because it was so early he goes you need
to hire somebody who knows how to make a
deck I will never forget that by the way
it took us another three years before we
actually knew how to make a deck we we
are the fat we are the fastest
organically grown to a hundred million
dollar revenue agency in the industry's
history and we win no RFPs
like we're just incapable because we
come in with a philosophy we're not
willing to like you know everybody sells
on an idea and it's just not something
you know we have pregnant it we we flirt
with it but like the truth is we have a
we have a philosophy which is a couple
things that we believe in that I think
are unique one
we believe that volume of creative is
the cost of entry of relevance of the
next decade and that we think this world
needs to understand that quantity does
not mean lack of quality and more
importantly what is quality you know for
example I think the rise of copywriting
is going to be profound over the next
decade because I don't think people
understand that the copy' change
literally the copy that associates every
block every post on Instagram Facebook
Twitter and things of this nature that
will continue to grow in attention is
massively important to the output of
success we become so visual it's so
video and Instagram doubt that people
are mailing in copy for all of you they
have your own ambition to grow your
Instagram as cop i watch copywriters in
my company who are interested in growing
their Instagram mail in copy
because they've been sucked into how
visual the medium is so um volume to us
is imperative we also think that
Facebook and YouTube and whatever the
Facebook and YouTube and Instagram of
the day is that internet long-form video
is actually where brand building is
being done not in the form of TVC you
know I think that I think that we have
to have a conversation in this industry
about things actually being consumed you
know and I think that common sense needs
to actually be part of the conversation
it is 2019 the far majority of people
all across the globe are watching OTT at
scale there is so little network
television being consumed in major 10
markets US Europe like Asia like so
little and then for that person actually
that first while they're not watching
the show and if they're even watching
the show for them to serendipitously
watch a commercial it's just not
happening like watching a commercial is
getting dangerously close to like
looking up the yellow pages like and yet
we celebrate it like nobody's business
and I think we have to challenge that
there's no way in your careers that TV
commercials are going to be on the
pedestal it's impossible
you're basically you know I look at it
like this it's a us-centric example I
know we've got a lot of people here but
every country in the world has its major
retailers and has its emerging internet
retailers
I think this world continues to
celebrate Walmart and Target and big-box
retail while I keep beating the drum
that Amazon is here and it's going to be
a problem and I think that's the analogy
for creative we we have to have this
conversation like you can't celebrate
something nobody sees and so that's
important to me but make no mistake I
believe creativity is the variable of
success right the creative all the
strategy work which is imperative
all the other stuff you know we're a
fully integrated agency we have media
and creative under one roof I believe in
your career you will see all of the
agencies consolidate media and creative
under one roof it is not working for the
clients to have media and creative in
separate rooms because I'm sure you've
already seen this in meetings when it
doesn't work everybody does this the
media agencies like it's the [ __ ]
creative the creative agencies like the
[ __ ] media plan sucked and and that's
been unbelievably smart fortwo holding
companies to separate it and quite
profitable but the brands are starting
to not be happy and they're the ones who
write your checks and that will play out
so I'm excited about that you know I
started the agency with 45 people that
didn't work in the industry I knew
nothing about the industry I've read
nothing about the industry so I started
vaynermedia I built a creative shop that
I put media in the name I had both media
and creative under one roof and had no
idea that it was unique so we were doing
all these unusual things what it led to
is a very large agency that has not
played by the industry rules but has
driven business results for its clients
so now we do have 900 people globally we
do have the US LA and New York offices
and London and opening up Singapore and
very frankly feel very confident we're
about to get a big scope for the World
Cup in Qatar and that means Middle East
and looking at you know South America so
I think it's gonna be interesting to see
what happens I think because of some of
the awards were winning this week just
I'm feeling from the creative class here
a little bit of more of a okay you can
be in the club and I'm laughing I'm like
I don't want to be in the club I don't
mind to be in the club but there's only
one club I want to be in which is
wouldn't you want to be a creative that
in real life when you hang out with your
friends people know what you're talking
about like how many more times do people
here want to spend 20 years of their
life making TV see that when they talk
about it and they're like you know the
IBM spot and their friends and relatives
like I have no idea what you're talking
about and if they do it's because they
tried really hard to find it
right I think that people want to I
think if you're creative I think you
want it to be seen I just don't know
what else to say and I think you know
what Mike and Adam will tell you if you
decide the apt with them after this is
after having careers and fancy places
doing fancy stuff it's fun to make it
you know think about all the ideas that
you guys have had that we'll never see
the day of life like you guys are all 12
years away six years away four years
away from being the final decision-maker
to actually see something made right now
you're politicking and and strategizing
on how to convince the two people above
you to actually make the thing you
believe in you're not in the creative
industry you're in the internal politics
industry that's why volume will set this
industry free we have interns from day
one in ad school being able to see their
thoughts in market from the biggest
brands in the world literally in terms
of rep we've literally interns already
in our company that have had more pieces
of content seen by humans and some of
the people here that's real that's going
to play out I hope for all of you I want
you to be in a place where you get to be
creative for real instead of working at
a bank and fighting for a half pregnant
version of your idea to see the world
and that's why so many of you have to do
things on the side because you can't
scratch your itch
good what's your name what's your advice
to get them to see it in a new way from
a personal use like down down the right
they they're not seeing it from a person
that's up the ranks so here's what I
would say here's a really really
important piece of advice that I think
will bring you value
please don't stay quiet because you know
it doesn't matter and you know it won't
play well in the room now that doesn't
mean be like me and be super combative
it means be respectful but let me give
you one humongous piece of advice the
world's gonna change animatics are the
stupidest [ __ ] of all time it sews is
the stupidest [ __ ] of all time
it can't sustain itself and it will
break and it's getting closer than you
think so
it's important for you to share your
actual points of view in these rooms
because people are watching and right
now you may be frowned upon or it's
silly or it's naivete or it's a kid
talking but everybody's watching and
listening and in three years when that
person's fired and he goes to a new
place and they have to win in digital
they're gonna be like she knew and so
die on your sword a lot of you are
staying quiet because you know will help
you grow but you're not you're not a you
guys are agreeing to things you don't
actually believe in you're doing it
because within the four walls you work
in that's what you know the rules are it
seems like it makes sense the problem is
we're at a point of transition and what
always happens at a point of transition
is people you guys are in a very
peculiar spot you're the last of the
mohicans so you're you're gonna uphold
the past because it's gonna play in the
room but you're also gonna live through
a career where it's going to be frowned
upon when you when you know when you
apply to the progressive places they're
gonna want to know where you sit on this
what did you do about it we're going to
talk to the clients or the other people
if you don't have a track record of
least communicating your points of view
you're definitely not gonna have work
most of you are not gonna have
progressive digital work which is one of
the reasons you may want to do a lot of
that on your own accounts or sidestep
you don't have anything to point to when
[ __ ] hits the fan and [ __ ] is going to
hit the fan shit's starting to hit the
fan you're welcome
I did good it's a great question what's
your name thank latina it's a great
question I think intuition is deeply
foundational to doing great work and I
think it's a talent I I think you know
it's hard to greem you know it's it's
how I always talk about hard work
because I think it's something we can
all do you can decide if you're
ambitious and hungry you could decide if
you don't burn out that you could work
longer it's hard for me to be like
become more intuitive you know like how
the [ __ ] does that mean like like where
do you go with that I think it's super
important laughs at everybody talking
about a all I'm hearing about is AI
walking guys nobody knows what the [ __ ]
they're talking this is not a tech
industry this is not a technology based
industry this is a creative industry
like everyone's talking about ai ai is
so far away the way people are talking
about it like I literally was this thing
to people like we may not have a job in
three years
ai is gonna make up AI is know where
it's coming it's cool but like you know
everyone's on big data and research and
all this stuff and all we do is create
all these layers to take away common
sense intuitive 'no sand creativity that
is my biggest observation about this
industry for an industry that's creative
the entire last 20 years has been
completely built to strip it all away
cuz it's run by banks guys who here
works for a holding company agency you
work for a bank
you work for a bank
you're working for a company that's
publicly held you're an excel sheet the
second you lose a client there's an
email sent out to the MD your MD has to
pay 20 points to the holding company as
a tax and then she or he is worried
about their bonus on margin and that one
conversation is around creativity you
know we have a very big point of view on
pushing in opposite directions yes we
love to listen to the customer but that
whole great saying of like if I listen
to my customer I'd make a faster horse
not a car we believe in that too so it's
a mix of our intuition and you know but
when we see something black and white
and you know I don't know how many know
the kool-aid the brand but the kool-aid
man the big thing would like break
through walls so we did like like you
know you see on Twitter now the designs
where you make pictures at it it's
[ __ ] what's it called yeah cool so
when we see something like that we go
from that now Mike and team is I da ting
to something we call bridge videos
what's happening back home now when they
see virality or something that's got
something now they're i da ting they're
not doing research in a bubble you know
our strategy team also has had to deal
with this it's no longer six weeks of
them leading the witness to where they
want it to go right and then giving you
a brief and then being mad at you for
not doing what they thought right and so
we're you know we're looking at it and
now they're deciding what one two three
minute video are we gonna make for a
pre-roll YouTube for YouTube for
Facebook for IG TV because we know those
videos are gonna get seen and if those
get seen the reason we call them bridge
videos is then that becomes our Super
Bowl spot because we think Super Bowl is
actually getting seen we think Super
Bowl is the best ad in America and we
think every other TV spots the worst
besides banner ads they're the worst we
had something on planters right Mike
yeah so we died on who's a very famous
college basketball player had a sneaker
break during a game we jump in and mr.
peanut does something
it catches it builds it builds it leads
to us to actually make us planters
sneaker that came out yesterday there's
nothing more fun there's nothing more
fun for us than selling ideas that
already have proof from the consumer
behind it
you know like you know I see reactions
you can imagine how much more ammo we
have walking in and it's qualitative
ammo a lot of times we talk because it's
easier to understand numbers 300,000
17,000 I promise you a lot of our
clients say yes
yeah they hear the numbers but then we
show 10 or 15 screens of quoi
I live on quoi i read only I read all I
do for a living is post content and read
all the comments yeah somewhere yeah
somewhere
keeping being on Facebook and Instagram
or do you think are the next big apps
I'm not sure
and I never care you know I'm only an
ion li care about this moment by the way
if television network drops their prices
by 80% I will buy a fuckload of
television you know so I don't know you
know and I don't get you know as much as
I love Facebook Instagram YouTube you
know those things in six years you'll
watch videos online of me saying it's
[ __ ] because the price became too high
for what the attention is and so I
always first think about the price of
the attention and then I think about
being a contextual creator in it one of
the things that we do very poorly in
this industry as well is make our
creative contextual for the distribution
you can't post the same video on
LinkedIn and Instagram and expected to
do the same thing the mindset of the
consumer even you yourself are different
when you're in your Instagram feed when
then when you're in your Linkedin feed
we do not have good enough conversations
around context and mindset in
consumption let me let me I'll get back
to you I promise
that is the creative process here it's
so quick
what is the process there or what
one thing that's probably unusual a
little different is we try to push and
we successfully have been able to push
our clients to realize the reason that
all of their businesses are down is they
need to be marketing in a relevant way
to 15 different cohorts not one there is
no 18 to 35 the [ __ ] is that you know
just look at look at all the different
Creed's and like not don't forget about
the way you all look your mindset the
psychology so one of the considerations
is upfront through common sense you know
like show me any brand right now and I
can give you ten of their meaningful
cohorts right now I understand it's
targeting moms I understand within moms
and I'm gonna use America now but with
the UK and Singapore that there's
different income levels there's
different races there's different reach
I think everybody in the world realizes
there's different Americas within
America you know there's a lot going on
and so if I'm gonna go after twenty
eight year old woman and she happens to
love Donald Trump and she happens to
make five hundred thousand dollars a
year you can imagine my video or my
piece of content on Instagram for olay
should be different than me going after
a spanic woman who's 28 who lives in New
York who hates Donald Trump and who
makes seventy three thousand dollars a
year you can't make that same piece of
content not just to think about what I
just said think about how far that
actually goes this industry sells
vanilla ice cream and it's and it yells
it in a place where nobody hears it
that's what this is all about this whole
week is about selling vanilla ice cream
and selling it to a room that doesn't
exist that to me is a problem so so
cohorts yes culture one of the
considerations is a sure Adam and
Michael tell you one of the wildest
things is we put the client and every
person touches the business our project
managers everybody in a whatsapp slack
or text read and all the I da ting
happens inside they are with the client
one of the things you know we'll find
out is that the client gets excited and
they start coming up with ideas and we
start making it one of the most fun
things has been watching my creative
team that cat audacity that's a
the client doesn't have good ideas watch
client ideas do well better than their
ideas that's humbling that's fun for me
to watch so it becomes a very humble
very safe very make very ideas driven
environment which just think about those
words so cohorts the work flow a lot of
listening strategy and insights happens
after the contents in the market not
being tested yes yes yes yeah so pretty
easy our you know our retention rate our
exit voluntary exit is 5.3 percent so I
don't know how many creatives you know
one thing that I'm sure if you talked to
Mike and Adam and not me come to Boehner
at 6:30 at night and tell me how
burnt-out people are we just have nobody
in the [ __ ] building like you know
I'm a hustler but like there's nobody in
the building at 6:30 at night any night
at vaynermedia there's like six people
of nine hundred people I'm being dead
serious with you so I understand that
some people you know I think everybody
will understand this I I we have an
unlimited vacation policy unlimited we
have nobody in the building at 6:30 we
have a founder that puts out a ton of
propaganda of hard work we have humans
that there's people who can burn
themselves out working 30 hours a week
because of their DNA their anxiety
levels so without knowing who you're
referring to or how many as many to you
know I think there's a let me promise
you one thing and again Mike and Adam
are probably better when I leave to talk
to there's an incredible perception of
who we are there's a lot of weird things
on you let me give an example
people are not self-aware when they get
fired and you've all sorts of weird [ __ ]
that happens
and I spent two three years telling
people who were mad at me for getting
fired to go to glass door and leave
negative reviews that is the reverse of
what every agency does I do that because
I think emotional intelligence back to
me saying intuitive is the only thing
that matters and I think that anybody
that believes Yelp reviews or Glassdoor
reviews or any anonymous reviews like
secret and whisper are deeply deeply
cynical or don't have emotional
intelligence so I use these perceptions
as ways for people not to enter I think
if you come and you actually spend time
and actually look under the hood I think
we have it I mean I'll be honest with
you I'm disappointed in the work ethic
at vaynermedia there's not a [ __ ]
soul in the agency at six-thirty so I
think we handle it pretty easily I look
at how many people voluntarily leave our
company you know I look at things like a
creative who left and came back three
weeks ago that we both know we're just
you know I think we have it really
really good I think that there will oh
you know we're always trying you're
always trying to be better
the reason the chief heart officer
Claude has more power than the CFO Allen
is because we're very warm and feelings
and but you know some people are able to
burn themselves out regardless of the
room you create for them you know and so
you know and by the way one of things
I'm trying to be more conscious of is
maybe they do look to me as Gary Vee and
maybe they're taking on that pressure
I'd hope that they see what's happening
in their day to day but that's that's
how I see it please
yeah I felt great about it like I feel
I'm like pumped about your quiet I don't
I you know here's what's amazing and
this is how I've thought about it you
and I appreciate that content and I
could tell it was it came from a good
place the truth always wins right you
know I mean you know Harry you might be
a great Harry just came from bbdo like I
remember when we interviewed very recent
she's only been here for three two
months you know and so I think the
biggest thing that's going on with our
shop is perception versus reality and I
and it's on purpose to be very frank I
don't want people to know what we're
really up to because if this town really
knew what I was up to they would be way
more scared and would be doing way more
things about it because let me tell you
what I'm doing here right now I have no
interest in recruiting you I'm
interested I'll to be amazing I'm
interested I'm interested in inspiring
you to start your own shop and never
sell it to a holding company that's what
I'm doing with my 45 minutes here that's
how we're gonna make this industry
better the reason this industry has so
many you know inclusion issues burnout
issue is because your [ __ ] excels you
guys are Excel cells every one of you
that raised your hands are lined for
nineteen columns see you are that is how
these companies are run I know it
because I'm a businessman so you like
that one that's good one so so so so
what I want is for you to think about
this world if you imagine a world where
instead of making two hundred eighty
thousand or three hundred fifteen
thousand being a senior creative at a
holding Co you have a business that's
your shop doing eight hundred thousand a
year which trickles down to you making
instead of 282 sixteen but you're
[ __ ] eight thousand times happier as
a human being
it's paid so the question was volume
sets the end of creative industry free
the question was is that organic or as I
paid it's often often paid because as
you guys all know the organic channels
for a lot of our clients where are we
going right what's crazy about payday
that's first time I got goosebumps so we
said a lot of things here think about
how much I must believe in this it's
scary to me that you can spend $80 and
get massive insights like I don't think
people understand especially if you
don't do pain at all or when you do paid
the paid guys and gals that are here
they spend 800,000 against something
they think it's all reach everybody
loves [ __ ] reach here that reaches
potential reach not actual consumption
you believe in GRPs you know you believe
in impressions come on you know
awareness about
we are and we're also putting it against
sales data so one of the reasons we're
really working is they're running this
creative and then it's running within a
one-mile radius of Albertsons or Tesco
or Sainsbury or you know Walmart and
then you're getting feedback loops that
are not just quantity qua I mean we
planters was declined or flat for nine
straight years one hundred and eight
months like straight the first month
before we did the Super Bowl spot which
aired in February in January just on
this volume model we grew the business
two percent that's a big deal for them
like that's real it just because people
are seeing [ __ ] I mean it's like
marketing works all day long you just
have to see it and it has to mean
something to you no no I'm just loving
she's trying to get her second question
in and I'm trying to balance it out
we're just having a fun we're having a
fun game yeah we have that the one thing
that we have is every account and we
don't have this everywhere all the way
yet because we're just rolling us out
but we're really close now every account
has three full-time creatives 100%
dedicated to the logo even when it's a
500,000 dollar fee account and that
person is a copy person a design person
and then a what we call a shreditor she
or he is doing film and post-production
as one person kind of what Darach does
for me and and again as you can imagine
that production value when you're making
five thousand pieces of content is not
necessarily the films that you know it's
it's it's native it's the [ __ ] that you
actually like when you're consuming
content and some of it can be very high
production value and we just chop a
bunch down if some of it could be grab
your iPhone make this video on the
counter and post it so they are there
and then above them are teams art and
copy CDs and you know what what's
happening is the
the core creator team is very allocated
a hundred percent on one account as you
go up those teams are spread out more
but they're all making I mean it's the
thing I put the most pressure on Adam
and Mike about is I need you on the way
to work right a tweet for Budweiser a
Rolling Rock to set the tone that if RG
CDs are making this is a making culture
you have people that start hitting gcd
level that never make a single thing for
710 you make a single thing I'll talk to
you after high
yes
why is called
because nostalgia is the most
underpriced thing in the world and you
know it sucks cuz ten years ago when I
was talking about it nobody knew now
everybody knows Fela champion marvel
like the whole culture is playing on
nostalgia like ten years ago I could
have bought Dragonball Z or pokemons I
could have bought this [ __ ] cheap now
everybody kind of knows way more than
they did ten years ago now I have to be
more clever now I have to find IP and
places people don't see it you know like
but it was I mean I was so on it I just
my timing didn't work out the world
didn't melt like we we work on Fela like
we're thrilled to be part of that
I mean Fela went from being irrelevant
to making dad shoes that every cool girl
wears that's cool that's interesting
that's like something nobody saw when we
started working on it couple years ago I
did a deal with k-swiss me personally I
have a case with sneaker k-swiss was off
the grid for 20 years like never on your
grid it was big right before Nike got
big it was cool with like ice-t and like
early dr. Dre and Mike Tyson it was 80
stuff and it was easy for me to reboot
it and be successful because nostalgia
sits nostalgia sit like any Nickelodeon
thing that I reboot will hit your radar
you know and so it's the most
underpriced thing because it makes you
feel something and it makes you feel
something about when you were in a much
happier simple place which always plays
to a grown-up when their life is
complicated and intense Doug feels look
really good when you're worried about
the world
thank you guys
[Applause]